so in one level this takes 11 instant of
time to kept to get all of these at the
end partial product since case N equals
4 and then if we would do a parallel add
of by pairing the ends then then we
would have log n levels of parallel ads
but each parallel add taking log in time
itself would give us login squared
squared log in of depth of the circuit
but the interesting thing is that you
don't need square vlog in depth so that
you can get log in depth of circuit even
though parallel ads I we prove each
parallel adder takes takes log in anyone
figure out how this might be possible
but lots of zeros in there Austin zeros
in their yacht but that's not the answer
because when because there's a lot of
mixing going on in fact all right so I
don't think it's the zeros in fact I
claim that I can do this if I had n even
if I had a problem where these where I
had no zeros here I could still add up n
n bit numbers in log n time the Kennedy
the the caddy does not really depend
just I mean you can think of it as a gay
of a B and C are a b c and d aiba CA in
the middle of that helps i carry is is
quality my claim is that if i had
actually put in non zeros and renumber
these so that this would be being one p
0 and so on as i would actually get i
would actually be able to do it let me
change that notation in
in 76 a 584 b 76 a g0d 750 0 and this is
VI equals list and exxon movies 1 and so
on plus minus 1 now with zeros imagined
to the right and the left of the inputs
see I yqx i minus 2 it's like a
convolution okay now now claim is that I
that we can also figure out a way to
make an adder for four numbers that are
our eight bits and they each will and
the total time is going to be still
login
all right now this was something that
was invented before the era of divide
and conquer I think the first solutions
to this though came in the fifth late
50s so I don't expect that you might be
able to do it right online but this is
the key was to have a redundant
representation of numbers not to so that
you that we kept that that you carry
intermediate results in forms that is
not unique but that but but that you've
got rather if you imagine after you've
added two numbers that you keep the
carries and the and the other numbers
separate and then and then you have a
way of combining the socially represent
every integer in in redundant way every
integer is now represented as to n bit
numbers instead of one n bit number
whether there are many ways to represent
the same integer but it so then to add
you can imagine adding to n bit numbers
together now it has a process of taking
4 into 2 taking the 24 your ex and the
two foci represent why and getting to as
the as the Sun if you could and that can
be done with a circuit that requires no
carry propagation so it can be done in
inconstant you know some number of
levels of logic five levels or whatever
is there will be a circuit that a life
that will take four inputs into two now
it turns out that think about a little
bit you can also take three inputs into
to us a lot easier and there's no reason
why you have to even retain the the
integrity of knowing which numbers
you're adding and the need the need idea
is that that we can we can we can form
the circuit that takes three numbers
into two very easily that's it
see more than I have better so X sub X n
minus 1 x and y and minus 1 10 ZN minus
1 z 0 and the sum of those three numbers
to be you n minus 1 u 0 plus 2 VN plus
2v this so the sum of these three
numbers is equal to the sum of those two
numbers where you simply say that you to
buy equals something in visa vie and
what are the formulas for them well u
sub I is the number that you get by
throwing away Carrie so that's X I you
savour why I 0z on and VI is the similar
thing X plus y plus Z div 2 which is the
two out of three function so that's X I
Y or X i zi or is why i CR or all three
okay so now those are two then that's
the half add function that that's called
H that's module H to compute the two
outputs U and V as a function of XY and
z you'll notice that subgroup is always
I here in every case and since since it
turns out that X plus y plus Z or X I
plus y plus zi is equal to UI plus 2v I
then it's going to be true when you for
the whole binary number this this whole
has lead these all n bit numbers X with
some of these three numbers will be the
sum of these two no okay with me on that
so we have a circuit then that takes not
too many levels of logic maybe two or
three to calculate two numbers to n bit
numbers from three okay now the idea is
we starting out with with n in general
it should take log in in detail end up
in things fair if yeah we got in so weak
so we start off with with N and things
to add together and we now have a way to
combine 3 into 2 and now we want to get
a circuit with small depth that will
that will add them all together we have
a way to combine 3 into 2 so what would
be a nice way so I'm going to have to
erase to something so let's i miss
andrés that's not so what's the so let's
imagine now that i have i have a whole
bunch of numbers a of use capital X 1
capital X 2 capital experienc a blank
445 let's suppose I had five numbers and
I wanted to add them together in
parallel 5 binary numbers that i want to
add a mix together in parallel and i
have a way of combining free into two so
what should what would be a good idea so
so
rough take it I'll take advice from the
floor he take this tray uganda in down
first day yeah all right and you had
them together to get time to okay so i'm
selecting them I can sort of cancel
those out might get two more which I can
call egg 667 okay you just repeat that
and i can now repeat that and go this
way for example take those into it and
then i get x rayed x9 that's not quite
true so but if you had say six numbers
there then you in parallel you down take
the first three and get two in the
second three and get to but it is nicely
x4 and x5 just know i had and if i had
six you would you would you're giving
you would put to put them in the two
yeah well yeah Yeti ok need and they all
i have for so now I have to decide which
three to do and I can not connect even
the two okay now i have throw that souls
come into two they just a normal edition
and now i have a now i have my parallel
edition once you get done too and we
can't use the 32 to trick anyone but and
so then we do a parallel audition which
we know we can do in log in time yeah
but now what was wrong with this idea of
going the other except you know
decorating so these three were we're
going into these two then these three or
going into these two and now i have
three left 09 so that would go into x 10
x 11
doesn't that work yeah check out Sutton
thought now you give me as much
parallelism because I've seen it before
but using a trace of the structure like
that I do it work that way and I still
think you're leaving you can set up
eight years yet hundred of hundred uh
something like that this engineers is
reducing one yeah work were used to sing
constructions were whereby you go say
three to one or two to one but three to
two is a little bit harder to see what's
happening but in three in the case of a
been to one or three two one operation
this method of always combining the
three at the top and putting at the end
is in fact minimum that's like a
hospital if we if we even if it's enough
if the exes were and somehow we're it
ranked in order of size you take taking
the largest and putting them into the in
well I don't know how we're trying to
minimize levels not sighs here but you
get the first levels by by this method
of take off the up awfully off the left
and put on to the right because the the
X is occurring order of increasing level
and are always combining things at the
at the lowest level whenever you can so
if we started out with nine inputs for
example then we would then in the first
unit of time we would actually do this
reduction 333 into two to two and then
we have six and that would be nice if
you do three and three again but even if
even if you don't set out with a
multiple of three this method is as good
as you can do I believe it can be shown
and the number of levels is what
asymptotic Dennis and his biggest I
within thinks how many levels to this
tree if we were only three to two the
quite well Eastern
log base 3 those always better you're
not base 2 of 3 yeah 1.5 HP on service
is the of it I mean this is me you're
dividing times log in like that way it
looks okay well we start out with about
3 to the K things then you would expect
something like K levels something like a
logic because we we get up at every
level we get a factor of two thirds and
so that would take so in k levels we'd
get down to 2 to the K so it isn't quite
right now add center so in k levels this
takes us down the to the case so so the
actual the actual factor is what T of 0
3 n is equal to on more or less less
obvious occurrence 1 plus T of two
energy
yeah it strengthened spacious because we
start with three n objects and then we
wind up with two week after one level we
get to we get to it they're kind of guy
flicks you guys could trace one but you
say so now we should and now the
conjecture is that T of n is equal to C
times log in and we questions what is C
right so we try to find out what what
value can solve this so that says that C
times log of 3 n its supposed to equal 1
plus C times log of 2 N and the logins
cancel just let me take off see login
off of both sides of the equation and so
that would actually be better be enough
to determine c c is equal to 1 over log
3 minus log 2
did I do it right and log 3 is 1.58 not
too is LG is what I should have been
doing here cramsey in the next LG log by
log base 2 because it has only two
letters so the large thing is 1.5 eight
minus life to is one so that's about
point 1 over point 58 that's the coat
that's the that's the number of levels
before we get under if you want and then
there's something right Dizzy's natural
log there if you want it to me that they
DIF admit doesn't because of this yeah
yeah whatever log is disavow
inconsistent my calculations are okay in
fact you can use the log base seat or
something log base 10 versi doesn't in
and make it equal to 1 yeah time oh okay
two-minute warning it's open all right
so that's what this circuit does for the
multiplier let's go back to that all
considered games what yeah log to base
was going fine would probably work
pretty even if you just put it in the
rock to base right by bases are three
halves because this is log of 3 half so
C is this really went over log of 3
halves and therefore this is log n over
log 3 I so it is equal to so this is
equal to log from 1.5 of it it is every
day that the number of this reduces from
three to two so that's a good yeah
that's it so it's one yeah 3 halves
easily is indeed the face of the logs
there good now um this so the final
thing is that this multiplier circuit it
consists of two 8-bit numbers and as I
say worthwhile to generate to generalize
to 2k bit numbers for K equals 3 when
you're testing
and first of all we just form the real
one bit products by taking end so I
that's what the ball apply this is the B
module which is a x by a bite by a bit
and shift then then we do these are
which is a reduction of three inputs to
two inputs and so I use a double
subscript notation there but it's
exactly what I like we wrote on the
board so we start out with with the
first subscript 0 1 2 and and and we I
guess initially we had zero to seven so
then when I is 0 3 I 3i plus 1 3 I plus
2 is the 01 to 2i plus h 2i plus 9 is
equal to 8 9 so you put your getting new
inputs called x8 next nine state then
we're going to add at the next bus we're
going to add three four five and call
those 10 and 11 and so on for I equals 0
to find and then finally that the two
things that are left are going to be 18
and 19 and use the parallel adder and
that's the that's the result of the
multiplication so this is a circuit that
takes to that takes a 16 input god it
gives us a total of 65,000 possible
inputs and for each of these were
supposed to compute the correct 16 bits
of output and and when you're going all
is put together you should get that many
gates so the first thing to do is write
a little program that that converts that
builds an internal computer
representation of the circuit then and
verify that you do in fact get 401 gates
all right i'll see you on thursday for
the
last let's go around on cryptography
also remember well commented and
programs accompanied by a write up our
are due for your feedback from the
friendly ta just performing on TV was
not the end of that problem you're also
supposed to turn in your conclusions and
not explain explain what you did and why
okay testing purpose I thought they were
doing today but they are yeah